oh hello and welcome to the pandemi's
wow it's great to finally see people
again
thank you for risking everything to be
here thank
me for risking everything to be here you
know what they say
you can't have a virus without a host
jimmy kimmel kicked off the 2020 emmys
on sunday amid the coronavirus pandemic
with sarcasm humor and a fake audience
why would you have an award show in the
middle of a pandemic
no seriously i'm asking why are we
having an award show in the middle of a
pandemic
and what the hell am i doing here this
is the year they decide they have to
have a host
yeah if you like me are totally
triggered by a large crowd of people
sans masks fear not that footage of
hollywood's a-listers sitting
close af actually comes from emmy's past
of course i'm here all alone of course
we don't have an audience
this isn't a maga rally it's the emmys
yeah
he went there but while jimmy had a
little tv magic at his fingertips
he took full advantage let's have a
standing ovation for me
well played jimmy well played but
back to that question why have an award
show now
in the middle of a global pandemic my
god do we need fun
this has been a miserable year it's been
a year of
division injustice disease
zoom school disaster and death
we've been quarantined and locked down
we've been confined to our homes like
prisoners in
a dark and lonely tunnel and what did we
find in that dark and lonely tunnel
i'll tell you what we found a friend
who's there for us
24 hours a day our old pal television
the 52 year old late night host
explained how the evening would work
after first taking a little hand
sanitizer perched on top of
what else an emmy award instead of
bringing the nominees to us
we went to them we have live feeds to
and from
more than a hundred locations around the
world and these
are tonight's nominees hello everybody
congratulations yeah that right there is
a giant screen with all the knights
nominees who were ready
and standing by to be fed into the show
for each award
what could possibly go right wild
right it's a massive undertaking
leading up to the big show jimmy opened
up about how they planned on pulling it
all off
because we can't really rely on people
operating
their equipment at home we are sending
out these packages these like video
packages it's a box and it has a camera
in it it will connect you right to the
emmys
and i guess the hope is that after the
emmys people
will send this stuff back i don't know i
don't think i would if i won
i would send it back if if i didn't win
i would keep it that would be my
award for the night of course this
year's unusual ceremony broadcasts live
from the staples center in downtown los
angeles
instead of the emmy's usual home in the
nearby microsoft theater
we are shooting at staples center
because it's the biggest
possible venue so we want to space the
few people that will be there out as
much as possible
as for jimmy he was just excited to work
his jokes on that
faux crowd for me i love writing the
monologue jokes that's the most fun part
about it
my motto uh during my talk show is
90 is fine uh in this case we want to
give somewhere in the neighborhood of
98 to sometimes even up to 100 percent